هذا هو الهدوء الذي سيسبق العاصفه سيكتب
الى هنا صباح الثلاثاء الرئيس السابق
وسيتوجه الى الطابق الخامس عشر في هذا
المبنى وهو مقر المحكمه الجنائيه العليا
في نيويورك
وسيقف امام القاضي والاستماعي نحو اربعين
تهمه موجهه اليه
بالفساد والاحتيال في مجال الاعمال ومن ثم
هناك سيكون عدد كبير من المتظاهرين في هذه
الحديقه
وسيكونون من مناصريه بالطبع ونرجو ونامل
ان لا تتسم بالعنف
مدينه نيويورك حضرت اعداد كبيره من
رجال الشرطه وهم اكبر جهاز للشرطه في اي
مدينه امريكيه
ولكنه وجودهم هنا معنا مع الصحفيين مثلا
ومعنى في ناحيه الاخرى ومع زملائنا هنا
الذين يعملون وقربهم منا يجعلنا على
على اصابنا في واقع الامر لان تاريخهم في
هذا المجال تاريخ معروف للجميع وتذكرنا به
احداث السادس من يناير عام 2020